[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's been here in Miami car tester eNOS
Petra is in Miami Florida for the
presentation of smarts new electric car
the smart electric drive has been on the
market in the United States since 2010 a
full 1/4 the third generation smart sold
here were electric cars eNOS is going to
test drive the new 4th generation smart
fortwo electric drive enger' minee only
about one out of every hundred new cars
is electric so there's still some way to
go to establish this type of drive as a
viable alternative
the latest electric smart is aimed
primarily at city drivers Smart has been
offering electric drive for several
years now introducing the first
generation 4 lease only the company or
official clients
[Music]
I'll connect of smart explains that
right from the beginning the smart was
designed for electric drive specifically
the concept included space for the
battery pack and an electric motor
without the buyer having to sacrifice
any of the interior space when switching
to electric drive this means the entire
model range two-seaters convertibles and
four-seaters could be delivered in
electric versions all smart fortwo is
whether conventional or electric drive
whether for America or other markets
roll off the same assembly line and
humbug France the interiors are
virtually the same the car is ready to
go when the word ready lights up in
green in the display
[Music]
enos points out one feature the electric
smart has that it's conventional drive
sister's don't an indicator that shows
the battery status and above that
another indicator showing the energy
flow above the car has entirely newly
developed components it starts off with
barely a sound eNOS is having fun
getting up to speed with 160 newtons of
torque the electric smarts got the good
pickup typical of v's the indicator in
the center console tracks the energy
flow while on the road orange for
consuming power and green for
recuperation while braking or coasting
it's the recuperation that to enos feels
different in the American version when
she lets off the gas pedal she doesn't
feel the strong deceleration she has in
other electric cars the American version
like the European one has an eco mode
that sets the car up for more energy
efficient driving heinous notes that
even an eco mode recuperation while
slowing down is small when compared to
other electrics in the American version
the motors physical capabilities are not
used to full advantage Peter says the
Eco mode is set a bit differently in the
European version so when she lets up on
the gas pedal there the recuperation is
noticeably stronger
to save space the battery pack is tucked
into the underbody beneath the seats the
space available is just the same as in
the gasoline-powered Smart's the luggage
space is also unchanged
the battery capacity of 17.6 kilowatt
hours has not changed but the efficiency
has instead of 55 kilowatts as before
the fourth-generation motor puts out 60
giving it a snappy pickup the new smart
electric drive has added just a tad more
range from 145 to 160 kilometers on a
charge wolven lamp of smart points out
that their customer survey showed the
average smart driver covers 35
kilometers per day so given the range of
160 kilometers they've achieved for the
current smart the driver could manage
quite well for two or three days on one
charge more battery capacity would
result an additional cost for the car
the company preferred to make it
affordable to a great many buyers the
electric smart fortwo lists at just
under 22 thousand euros in Germany of
which four thousand may currently be
covered by the state purchase subsidy
for new electric drive cars a real
improvement in the fourth generation is
the new onboard charger on the German
grid it can recharge the smarts battery
up to 40% faster AG explains it smart
has made the onboard charger bigger than
in the previous generation vehicles so
the batteries can recharge faster but
many car owners use a household outlet
that's the actual bottleneck and there's
no way to speed that up if they used a
wall box or a public charging station
with a new 7.2 kilowatt charger they
could recharge it in about two and a
half to three and a half hours of course
the charging times can vary according to
the country's power grids a new even
higher output onboard charger is
available as optional equipment that
lets a German car owner charge the
battery pack from zero to 80% in less
than 45 minutes heinous observes that
for the fourth generation smart
concentrated on improving the ride
quality and the charging process the
range of 160 kilometers is plenty for
city drivers it's simply a question of
whether this electric car suits the
drivers lifestyle the new smart fortwo
electric drive will be hitting American
showroom floors before year's end
Europeans will have to wait till 2017 to
get the latest smarts and slipped
silently through town
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
most people probably know the name
McLaren from the Formula One racing
track but the British sports car maker
builds models for the road as well the
570s along with its relatives the 540 °c
and the 570 GT make up MacLaren's
entry-level sports series test driver
Lionel Dyson over finds the road going
570 not as uncompromising and purist
against its big racing brother the 650
but he says despite the 80 horsepower
difference this super sports car can
still reach top speeds of around 330
kilometers an hour
the mclaren 570s is intended as an
entry-level vehicle but it's not for
every pocketbook in Germany the sporty
British car sells for around 180 2000
euros but owners get quite a run for
their money
0 to 100 km/h and 3.2 seconds and a 600
Newton meters of torque the twin-turbo
3.8 liter v8 engine is every drivers
dream but most drivers will probably
want to deactivate the news start/stop
function these images speak for
themselves
[Music]
the 570s is superb and every way it
offers three drive modes for regulating
steering behavior engine and
transmission
[Music]
boscogn and our tester says what the
mclaren 570s does best of all is impress
he says no other car is so often
photographed or given the thumbs up
that's down to its extravagant design
promising a superb engine with matching
brakes chassis and razor-sharp steering
my notes tip for prospective buyers
order the Bowers and Wilkins audio
system he says it's almost as good as
the high-end Burmester sound systems
that Porsche uses the impulsive about
but of course in this model it's the
sound of the engine that is really music
to the ears
I know it says entering the car is
relatively easy but how to get out again
he advises placing the left leg over the
baseboard and the right leg pushing off
with your backside pull yourself up
words a bit if necessary and there you
are
in fact MacLaren's newly developed
carbon fiber mono cell body was
especially designed to ease getting in
and out I know sees the mclaren 570s a
multitasker for track country roads and
city streets
he points out two new features a glove
compartment and a vanity mirror he
doesn't get how you can correct your
eyeliner while accelerating from zero to
200 in nine and a half seconds it's a
sign that this McLaren is built not just
for racing but for everyday use
[Music]
sales of Audi second-generation q5 start
in early 2017 for years the first
version was the best-selling SUV in its
class worldwide the new q5 offers
sharper handling and more comfort on the
exterior the single-frame grille
dominates the aerodynamically flat front
with a massive frame prices for the new
premium SUV start at just over 45,000
euros in German showrooms for the 2017
model year compact best seller Mazda has
been extensively modified with big
improvements in technology comfort and
styling the design changes to the Mazda
threes front and back are combined with
additional assistance systems the Mazda
3 is still available as a four-door
sedan or a five-door hatchback the
entry-level price in germany is just
under 18,000 euros
[Music]
Martha says going on holiday with a
campervan can be great because you're
free to stop pretty much whenever you
feel like it but handling a campervan
like this is quite different to driving
a normal car Eimer offers training on
how to drive these vehicles safely and
Montes has come to check it out I'm who
my father is planning here in Northern
Europe it's certainly not the peak
season for campervan holidays right now
but even here many people like to get
away from the German winter at the
Sachsenring racetrack professional
instructors are on hand to show drivers
how to react correctly in every
situation and ensure they drive safely
the first consideration is loading the
vehicle correctly lot of gyres the main
instructor he says it's important to
look over everything once more before
you leave anything that can shift needs
to be stowed properly you need to draw
up a plan beforehand to ensure that
everything is correctly packed or
fastened down so it can't move
lengthwise or sideways past the sizing
on external pavilion links alone dick
perished on Konkan if the driver has to
hit the brake suddenly items that
haven't been properly secured can turn
into dangerous projectiles
[Music]
driving in a circle proves instructive
even for experienced camper van drivers
the participants practice a situation
where the driver has underestimated the
bend and approaches it too fast
[Music]
Suzy Delta the instructor explains that
the road surface is slippery and so you
start to slide the mistake most people
then make is that they start the steer
more when you move past the slippery
part there is a risk of the van tipping
over so it's important to reduce your
speed and practice breaking correctly
thus planes insult immune reacting and
decisively or braking incorrectly can
make the braking distance much longer in
some cases that can prove fatal
often drivers don't realize the trucks
need a longer braking distance
participants watch a test situation that
demonstrates why it's important always
to keep enough distance when driving
behind a truck
but Martha says the course doesn't just
focus on how to drive safely on the open
road what happens when you decide to
stop somewhere for the night if you park
your camper van at a campsite you often
have to negotiate your way past other
outsize vehicles there might be trees to
avoid as well and things that can start
to get complicated often be done thanks
Tuscan Sun should be like together
during the training the driver and
passenger get to practice working
together with one out on the road
signaling to the driver
how much room they have left to reverse
the instructors are always on hand with
useful tips
[Music]
[Music]
mata says the instructor helped him this
time but hopefully if you're going off
on holiday you won't be alone and so you
can ask your passenger to guide you into
parking spaces that makes a huge
difference the training course is
especially useful for beginners to help
them get used to driving a vehicle of
this size and get a feel for the
dimensions
[Music]
this participant says she'll be giving a
seven-point eight metre campervan so she
wanted to be prepared but the main focus
is teaching participants how to react in
an emergency those who appreciate both
their own and their vehicles limits will
drive more safely this participant says
she hasn't driven her camper van very
much so far she's learned a lot here
particularly how breaking and reversing
into a parking space some things she'd
never done before today as once again
Sean matters how much he doesn't know
even though he drives everyday there are
still many things he overlooks in daily
traffic and so it's good to practice
he'd recommend a road safety course for
every driver not just those with camper
vans so here fancy heights training to
do
[Music]
the easiest way to make the dream of
owning a BMW a reality is to choose the
one series starting at around 23,000
euros in Germany it's served as an entry
to the BMW brand for 150,000 new buyers
making it a key model for the Bavarian
car maker tester Android sim among sites
people who complain that things were
better in the past like more 3 door
compacts with rear-wheel drive and that
those models are now a dying breed but
he says there is still a car that fits
that basic description and that's the
BMW 1-series our 118 D model with the
urban line package starts at around 34
thousand euros in Germany the 8-speed
steptronic transmission makes the 0 to
100 kilometer per hour sprint in 8.1
seconds
the 1-series has a typical BMW exterior
the headlights feature the classic twin
circular design and then there's the
unmistakable two kidney radiator grilles
Bobby Andre says it's logical in a
rear-wheel drive for the engine to be
mounted lengthwise not transverse and
take up more length of the car than
width but actually at 4.30 3 metres this
compact BMW is only marginally longer
than the current VW golf engine
configuration leaves less room for
passengers and luggage says on thing but
his impression is that there's plenty of
room although not for a long vacation to
be exact the BMW offers 360 litres of
trunk space that's just 20 litres less
than the golf with front-wheel drive a
difference that most owners won't mind
the interior is definitely up to BMW
standard even if there is a lot of
plastic here it's of high quality
workmanship and as a pleasant feel
the most noticeable effect of the
rear-wheel drive is on the ride
[Music]
- dr. Condry explains it like this since
the front axle doesn't exert any thrust
the steering stays free from any drive
influence so no matter how much he
accelerates out of the curve the force
exerted on the steering wheel stays the
same that makes for easier handling and
doesn't falsify the feedback he gets
from the steering many drivers of
today's mostly front-wheel drive cars
have never known this kind of handling a
large number of drivers see rear-wheel
drive as a must in sports and race cars
since it means less of a temptation to
understeer at high speeds
[Music]
named Andre points have another feature
that along with the rear-wheel-drive
emphasizes the Beamer one series is
sporting ambitions the 8-speed
steptronic transmission with most
automatics to shift manually the driver
pushes forward to shift up and pulls
back to shift down but here it's the
other way around
Andre sees that as the more logical way
to do it because that's how it works in
race cars with sequential gearboxes so
the shift lever moves in accordance with
the g-forces when accelerating and
braking so it's a logical configuration
but unfortunately it hasn't become the
norm for the great majority of cars
because that's Andre observes the BMW's
1-series occupies a niche that no other
car maker will venture into right now
that may be a very good selling point
but it might not last long BMW makes
plenty of other models that don't have
rear-wheel drive the kind Hagen's
capable when harbinger of this
development was BMWs 2 Series active
tourer that utilized a transverse engine
with front-wheel drive to create more
space for the passengers this may very
well be the stars for the next
generation of the one series and that
would spell the end of the rear-wheel
drive
era for the compact class
[Music]
the 2016 Essen Motor Show has become far
more than just a tuning show often it's
more like an orgy of horsepower even
more than the sports cars and customized
production models it's the hot rods and
rarities that draw the crowds like this
1974 Chevrolet Monte Carlo with the
somewhat shamanic name spirit runner its
owner Brandon Gonzalez redid the paint
engines and hydraulics
[Music]
one of the most powerful set of wheels
at the fair is this pickup truck with
4,000 horsepower a thousand from each of
its four rear mounted engines it belongs
to New Zealand air Gordon transom
well I live in Las Vegas Nevada and the
car is registered and actually what I
did I registered it when it was a
regular truck and then I made all the
modifications and changed we do not have
any rules per se of what you do after
and as long as it has the basic
requirements brakes lights horn you can
drive anything and we're very very
fortunate because I know in most parts
of Europe you but this would not be
allowed but Oklahoma Willie is even more
powerful
Perry Watkins the British owner of this
1958 VW pickup mounted a Rolls Royce
Viper 535 jet engine on the back capable
of five thousand horsepower and speeds
up to 430 kilometers per hour
for safety reasons he's not even allowed
to fire it up at the show
widebody super sports cars have been
popular in japan for over two decades
now the trend is starting to take hold
in Europe as well
tuning icon Wataru katsu has fans of all
ages they're here to see is customized
ferrari 485 it's got a 570 horsepower v8
engine and it's worth some 300 thousand
euros
another new trend is souped-up electric
vehicles or EVs the idea is not so much
to beef up the performance as to enhance
the appearance this Tesla has been
completely restyled with a body kit
carbon fiber hood and air suspension
it's the new increase he alongside the
old and crazy that gives the Essen Motor
Show as special character the oldest car
at the fair is a 1929 sit the one
delivery truck you could call it one of
the very first hybrids a wood-burning
gasifier was added to help out the
combustion engine it actually still goes
the most expensive car at the show is
this maserati 250f insured at a value of
5 million euros sterling moss watched
his Formula One career in this vehicle
which may well be the sweetest race car
of all time
[Music]
[Music]